let's get into that first big story Joe
Rogan Leeds move to getter after Twitter
bans Dr Robert Malone rep Marjorie
Taylor green Rogan's move comes after
Twitter banned rep Marjorie Taylor green
and Dr Malone for coveted misinformation
but I don't think Joe Rogan jumped uh
signed up for a getter because of
Marjorie Taylor green I think he did it
mostly because Dr Malone told him on his
show he was banned and then he signed up
forget her now I want to make one very
important point before we get into all
of this stuff Joe Rogan is the biggest
podcast in the world even still after
leaving YouTube and iTunes still the
biggest podcast I gotta say
I see his numbers put out by uh um you
know Spotify compared to Nielsen ratings
Spotify is saying this is a Luke
Rutkowski on on Twitter I heard about
this guy before he's pretty good he's
pretty good Joe Rogan Experience 11
million viewers per show
wow
11 million that is substantially larger
than uh what we get on this show across
the board true and uh we could only hope
to ever reach that level of of
viewership but that's Joe Rogan of
course it is when he says hey guys I'm
kind of worried about the censorship I'm
gonna get up on getter there's gonna be
a lot of regular people who aren't
deeply entrenched in politics we're
gonna do the same and this is huge in
the battle against censorship it could
be good could be bad now it is good but
there could be some bad to it I'll say
this
a lot of people who are being censored
who have been banned have found a voice
on other platforms like parlor Gap
getter Etc but the the big Tech you know
collusion comes after all these
platforms we saw what happened to parlor
we saw what happened to gab gab starts
building at home its own infrastructure
getter may experience something similar
but at the very least for the time being
if you get banned from Twitter that's
somewhere you can go and see many people
talking about you know certain ideas
it's not perfect
but I I think coming into this year
the big risk is that if we have two
separate Echo Chambers and people can no
longer communicate at all well then I
think the divide in this country is
going to get way way worse absolutely
we're having one of the key instrumental
figures that created the MRNA vaccine
we're having Congress men and women
being banned from expressing their
dissent towards the the the narrative
and they're getting axed they're getting
their ability to talk to their
constituents removed away from them by
what power what God like Authority big
Tech social media that literally just
deemed it to be not appropriate for the
general public to hear I'm sorry I mean
once you start censoring information
once you stop eliminating the people to
even have a debate or an honest
conversation you're on the wrong side of
history and what Joe Rogan has done is
he has put people who have been censored
in a way where their voice could
actually be heard they could actually
release their ideas to the general
public and this is a huge step against
the big Tech social media monopolies and
this is why I joined getter because and
again I don't even know much about
getter I still need to do my research I
still want some kind of reassurances
that getter won't become the next
Twitter but but but still this is a
swell of movement of people saying hey
this is crazy I I can't deal with this I
want free speech is that did you sign up
for getter uh I have not signed up for
ghetto yet I am on Rumble which is a
YouTube competitor yeah um yeah we use
rumbleman so uh you know I think
something important to acknowledge here
I think a lot of people you know they
look at these decisions by these
companies and they say Well they're
private companies they're they're
behaving and that they get to control
who who are their users and their
customers are just as any store or any
business organization would something
people have to understand is that over
the past few years the government has
increasingly leaned on these companies
you know Democrats will bring these
people before hearings though they'll
bring up inflammatory content and
they'll talk about this and they'll
basically ask the companies why they
aren't censoring more now the government
of course has various regulatory Powers
they could impose on these companies
that could you know cost them profit
they could reduce their market share
that could even break them up and I
think that a lot of what these companies
have been doing over the past few years
uh for instance what they did with the
hunter Biden stories where Facebook and
Twitter were throttling the story making
it difficult to even click the link uh
to go and read the New York Post story
about uh President Biden's son I think a
lot of what they're doing they're doing
that preemptively to avoid potential
regulation from the Democrats so it's
not so simple as private companies
simply making enlightened decisions you
know playing Hal monitor on speech
they're actually doing this with
political aims uh in mind in that they
know that this party is in power in
Washington right now so they have to
keep them happy I think there's a lot of
Democrats I think there were some
Democrats who were interviewed about
like problem who were very much in favor
of Marjorie Taylor green being removed
from Twitter they probably wanted them
to go further than that so I think you
know you have to understand this is this
whole thing's an ecosystem it's not just
a company acting in a vacuuming I think
Facebook did a 24-hour suspension of
Marjorie Taylor green almost immediately
after Twitter removed right in concert
I would I would actually disagree with
you I don't think big Tech is afraid of
politicians I would say politicians are
afraid of big Tech especially with the
amount of money that they put into the
lobbying business I think they're the
biggest uh I one of the biggest uh
lobbying efforts in all of Washington DC
and they control a lot of power because
they get to see everything that
politicians do now you don't need the
CIA anymore you got Facebook literally
knowing when you're going to take a dump
so if they know that they're tracking
and databasing all these politicians and
probably have a list of dirty laundry
against them and they could go to them
be like hey we know what you Googled we
know what you looked into we know the
private videos you watch on this and
this website we could release that to
the general public unless you do what
you want us to do so I think big Tech
especially with how they were working
with the intelligence agencies from
their beginning are the ones really in
charge here from my perspective but
again I might be wrong think about how
insane it is to take down and actively
sitting politician right Twitter Banning
Marjorie Taylor green I mean first of
all Banning Trump that was crazy people
don't realize this man you get you get
the cnns you get all these networks
being like an Insurrection occurred so
we must remove the current president
from all of these social media platforms
so you can't communicate he's not going
away his followers aren't going away
this is not shutting anything down it's
only proving to the people who don't
like you you're as bad as they said you
were if you've got people if they're if
they're telling us that there's an
Insurrection you've got people who
genuinely think the Democrats and the
neocons are like evil and need to be
removed or whatever and then you decide
that the one person they do like Trump
is going to be removed from public
discourse that just makes it worse it
makes it substantially worse I think
back to I think it was George Washington
there was this um
I'm I'm blanking on the guy's name but
there was a a conspiracy do you guys
remember this like the revolution After
the Revolution America couldn't pay its
debts and a bunch of soldiers weren't
paid so there was like some Insurrection
and George Washington was like no no we
gotta let these guys go if we if we
prosecute or persecute them it'll only
make things worse oh yeah I can't
remember I can't remember the full
details and you know we talked about on
the show Once but that's what a lot of
people talked about back during the
interaction people uh much smarter than
I mind you they said perhaps amnesty for
these people is the best way to do this
to say look we're we we are we are one
country we need to come together we
don't want to make these problems worse
Instead The Establishment the
intelligence agencies the doj have all
done everything in their power to make
this as bad as possible and it's not
just the doj it's not just the
government it's the big tech companies
now removing Marjorie Taylor green for
what no coveted misinformation they said
and Dr Malone now Marjorie Taylor
Green's not a scientist but she is a
leader in the federal government they
may not like that she is but she is Dr
Malone is a scientist a dissenting one
when you ban dissent that's the opposite
of science they're just proving to
everyone the problem is is bad or as bad
or worse than they realized and and
let's let's remember something when
like-minded people gather together they
tend to become more extreme right so it
was in the past it would have been a
matter of you know Dr Robert Malone's on
Twitter he's on YouTube he's discussing
these things with other scientists you
can weigh what he says against other
people the truth can win out that way
right let's say someone's a huge fan of
Roger Taylor green now they're just
gonna go watch her on rumble or view her
messages on getter they may not say
someone debating with her discussing
with her they might grow even more kind
of close-minded in that direction right
they're they're reducing contact between
people of different ideologies because
they're just deciding a certain
ideologies are verboten that they're
forbidden to be spoken they're ending up
segmenting and segregating people off
and that may actually create more
extreme Echo Chambers in the long run
and and you know I think that this again
I think because of all the political
considerations that are happening right
now I mean these companies tend to be
run by more left-leaning people they
have a more left-leaning government in
DC that they are are somewhat managing
or dealing with right now I don't think
they think three steps ahead when it
comes to a lot of this stuff right and I
think again that what you pointed out in
terms of those historical examples uh
we've seen that many times throughout
history not only with George Washington
excited after the American Civil War
there was a long process of
reconciliation between the North and the
South that wasn't resolved maybe for a
hundred years I don't think it was ever
resolved after World War II I think that
many of the Allies you know they kept
actually a fair bit of the German
leadership of course many of them were
brought to trial and executed but some
of the German leadership was maintained
some a big part of the Japanese
leadership was maintained and I think
they did that because they didn't want
to throw those societies into a further
Civil War they didn't want to make them
feel marginalized and repressed they
wanted to say hey look this war was
wrong we defeated you but we're going to
bring you into the community of Nations
now right they wanted to make them feel
included and I think that mostly worked
with Germany and Japan and Italy and his
acts as powers and I think that has
generally been the wiser path to to take
here and I think that yeah I in a few
days I imagine with the January 6th
anniversary we're going to see a lot of
mulling over this New York Times already
said every day is January 6th now right
you can't you can't move past it you
can't reconcile with these people you
can't try to come back to a normal
country they seem to be wanting there to
be some kind of civil disturbance or War
but it has no end point and it has no
goal either right because what would
that what was what does this conflict
entail even it's just a matter of
permanent grievance and resentment
divide and conquer I think it's
deliberate when you look at these Echo
Chambers they're not only created with
censorship they're created with the
algorithms that promote people from just
having their views regurgitated back to
them by people who have the same
political ideology and and I think it's
meant so we do fight each other so of
course we don't really truly look at
what's causing our problems we look at
each other and see that's the problem
our Common Man our neighbor we should go
after him we should fight them because
they think not like me and again that
type of ideology is absolutely fascistic
and it's disgusting and it's something
we need to fight back on as much as we
can right now take a look at this uh
this tweet here from everyone's favorite
CNN person now that Brian stelter he
says watch how this Twitter user mocks
reporters for talking candidly about the
trauma associated with the capital
attack I just quote tweeted it and wrote
trauma the trauma I like the I like the
first uh reply to it I think that's it
that's perfect the first reply oh Stewie
Stevie from Family Guy the trauma okay
here's what you need to understand if
you're on the ground during these like
riotous moments it can be stressful but
uh for many of us we've been through
tons of them I've been you know Brazil I
think was one of the most intense
Thailand was probably the scariest
because people were actually killing
each other there but to say that in any
way foreign conflict like there there
are foreign war reports and conflict
reporters much braver than I'm much
smarter than I who have traveled to many
countries facing real dangers who don't
have trauma and many do don't get me
wrong for journalists in America who are
not on the ground to be explained
discussing their trauma over an event
they did not witness I think it just
goes to show you how insane the whole
system is getting thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time